[Music]
Janet Jackson gets cozy with an old lame
the 51 year old singer has celebrated
the end of her state of the world tour
at STK Atlanta on Sunday she was joined
by ex-boyfriend Jermaine Dupri and an
eye witness tells et they cuddled and
held hands in the VIP section of the
upscale restaurant despite getting cozy
a source close to Janet tells ET that
she and Jermaine are not romantically
involved rather they are as the best of
friends
adding quote both Janet and demeanor
warm people so it's not unusual that
there would be hugging or hand-holding
even in public Jackson and Dupree split
back in 2009 after 10 years together and
a lot has changed since then
[Music]
in January Jackson welcomed a baby boy
Issa with her estranged husband Wisam
Amana three months later they called it
quits but earlier this month ET learned
that Jackson and Issa will spend the
holidays in England where al mana is
based the source says Amana allowed
Jackson to take their son on tour and
now he wants them back home for the
holidays and possibly longer adding
quote now that the tour is over they can
move forward with their divorce and
possibly a very contentious custody
battle
[Music]
you